this is the manger this means I'll
humbly lot Salaam alaikum peace be with
you the Dean show every week here to
help you understand Islam and Muslims
the most misunderstood way of life
except you know it's it's the most
misunderstood but this is a phenomenon
that it is the fastest-growing way of
life in the world that's right we got
white Muslims African American Muslims
Chinese Muslims and today we got a
Latino Muslim coming on the show his
life is like a it's like a modern day it
was like a drama action packed movie and
he's here to share his experiences with
us so sit tight right back on the D show
this is the theme this is the thing is
the thing this is the things
this is the Salam alaikum peace be unto
you walaikum Salaam holla Puerto Rico oh
ha ha ha ha ha how are you my brother
home the legatus I just want to break
the ice a little bit so Nadine show I'm
really excited that you're here Daniel
Hernandez correct and Abdullah is your
name now yes or I mean I mean this is
this is a myth it so let's start off you
don't you don't have to change your name
when you become a Muslim good correct
you don't have to do that do you know I
don't you don't you I mean so you're
Daniel hand down your hand Cecil can
also call you to this Abdullah the
servant of god yes now you aren't always
being called by this name I mean let's
back it up a little bit I'm very excited
for us to have you on the show you come
from a Latino background Puerto Rican
yes what's difference become bein Puerto
Rican Mexican way to speak you speak the
same language right we speak the same
language just the dialect is a little
bit different you know we compete you
know because of the music as well you
know they have salsa we have salsa how
many say it's ours now his hours and we
you know there's a little tug of war
historical yeah but I mean you can
understand each other right yes we can
yeah i did say house in span in puerto
rican house gasa gasa how about in
puerto rican same customer sir so it's
just a little dialing yeah okay great so
now tell us how Trussell about yourself
well I was raised in a Catholic
household my mother used to be a nun
uh-huh and she used to be in a convent
and teach more than 50 students and then
she decided to leave the convent and got
you got married with my dad and she had
us she bought us up always very
religious you know doing the Catechism
in own house always teaching us to pray
before eating before sleeping
you know always always keeping the
remembrance of God and she also gave us
the freedom to to choose she didn't
impose life on us so I was the smallest
one of my brothers and I always like to
make the challenging choices how many
brothers yep I have two more me and two
other brothers sisters also no no
disability correct and then I happen to
you have a low self esteem always trying
to just convince myself you know because
I had the bad experience in some schools
where I had a dream and the teacher
would tell me you know you're not gonna
make it you're not going to be that
teacher would tell you that yes so it
will crush my spirit and so then instead
of what why would a teacher say
something like that you know I it was
that the teacher was teaching in an
environment where she's not familiar
with yes he's from a different
environment but she will come because
it's her profession it was actually kind
of bitter else you know and and it's
like so what I did instead of making
easy for her to teach I made it
difficult oh I see I'm a troublemaker so
yes I you know I didn't I used to forget
you about it but it was something that
it hurt me and then you know through
life you know other experiences led me
to just make the wrong choices you know
then I started playing basketball I
started playing basketball in high
school you know and some of my friends
had issues so they were before the game
start drinking yeah alcohol and so on
and I would you know has dick as I
wasn't into it but there was some
factors that made me say you know let me
just let me just try it kind of how do
you at this time when you
when you you're about to have your first
sip of alcohol yeah no not this I mean I
had tried it before but this one was for
act like I really wanted it before I
just tried it because it was peer
pressure yeah you know but this one was
like I wanted to try it now you want to
be that gonna be a man yeah like I was
like like 17 that I wanted to do it yeah
and it wasn't it wasn't it just it was a
slope going down the hill so I would
we'll go we'll be in the games
intoxicated and the games turn into
chaos yeah so I ended up going further
than that and saying you know I wanted I
saw that you know the most of the in my
community of the object of the Latinos
that I know you know they either drop
out of school or they're just you know
working in jobs and not getting a degree
so I mean friends that I know it so I
felt bad about this I I want it to be
proactive I said I want to do something
about it you know I always I always
liked the inspirational movies you know
like like like movies like Malcolm X
yeah like in these leases were like the
movie south central when the guy goes to
prison and then you know in prison he
reforms his life and Dalia comes out to
a community and so I wanted to do
something like this so I started looking
here and there you know what what group
you know and then I say okay you know
this group is chose this ethnicity or
this nationality I became curious you
know and I wanted to be proactive so I I
saw this group and i joined it because i
was just some charitable organization
you talking about it will just like
change the world organs or what was just
luck it was a fear what was this no it
wasn't organ it like named an
organization but really you know it was
what what the media portrayed to be was
again oh so now when I introduce the
show I said you know we're going to talk
to this brother whose life was kind of
like a what I say what I say you know
like a live
action thriller so now things get really
i mean when you talk about games you got
shootings you got killings you got drugs
were you heading down that way this is
where things get ya exciting yeah
they're great they got they got they got
crazy and tell us a little bit we're not
going into details you know so because
there's a lot of people out there this
is cool you know we've part of familie
now yeah so they think this is the way
to go not knowing that you know what you
then up in jail or dead so we don't want
people to go down to direction so they
can connect with you who actually high
up in the ranks weren't you mm-hmm and
some of the some of the crazy things
that were going on I mean well the most
the most giver shot it no I never saw
that I did had no have you ever get shot
at no and I never got shot and never
never shot I mean I had there was times
where things were going to take place
but it was something that I had the
feeling I wanted to do it just because I
was loyal but somehow it never went down
and you know I had I know that they're
you know within the organization's there
were people that I had a friend who was
very educated but by the color of Allah
you know the destiny of Allah he
happened to be raised without a father
in a shelter yeah but when he was in
high school he was a valedictorian yeah
but he ended up in the streets so now
you know he's my he suppose my brother
in this group and he he needed a place
to stay so I don't to stay in my house
yeah you know but there were things that
happened you know is i'm going to say
things that happen in one year span and
this is what is that that turn where i
come in contact with Islam but that's
what let's hold right there that same we
got to go to a break okay I hold your
place request mr. Sherlock I woman sit
tight we're back with more Hannity show
I just want to say very simple massive
is the leading one of the grill for
things about our religion of Islam
is the emphasis on direct ritual and
prayer whom God directly there is no
intermediary the lights will go on after
the party and the party will end it's
very simple and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out we
might not make it to tomorrow and this
is something that we need to think about
the Dean show with Daniel Daniel my
brother see people you know they don't
understand that there's a brotherhood
here we worship one God him alone not
what he created and we we pray together
we fast together we do good things
together and we're brothers isn't it you
could be from China you could be from
Japan you could be from Puerto Rico and
we come together in Islam and we're
brothers in that beautiful yeah yeah so
again I'm excited that you here with us
now before we get into this Islam where
you took a turn and you know simply for
our brothers in humanity the not yet
Muslims i call them people who
potentially like all of us have this
ability to submit to God and this is
what Islam is calling you to submit to
the One God not to a man or a woman not
to a messenger a saint but the one guy
who created all these things isn't that
right yeah so tell us now before you you
took a turn in this beautiful direction
again you were experiencing everything
then the average person was experiencing
was there any joy fulfillment peace and
any of these things no yours I'm very
soon see that the one of the things that
i would i would ask myself it went out
when i got into this into this group I
began to ask myself what's my purpose in
life so I was okay i'm gonna i'm going
to make money so then i was out i will
go down that route you know trying to
you know make as much money as I can you
know the quicker the better so then I
ended up having money but still not
being content so then I said you know am
i if I find a partner you know might be
happy so I going and be no started going
you know and I was raised with my
parents and my parents you know they
gave me they showed me a model and when
I you know I see that the the prophet
taught us how to be a husband is similar
to with the way my dad dealt with my mom
and you know Mary 30-plus years
so I saw this so whenever I even I try
to have a girlfriend I felt that this
wasn't why I wanted marriage I wanted
something like real but I said let me I
want that feeling so I began going with
girls and I I still didn't feel content
then I said you know there no reason
have no no no peace and happiness no
always saying okay then let me let me
just you know below my friends and you
know have fun play basketball you know
hang out in this in the streets after
basketball you know let's go you know
like drink some 40s and so on and still
at the end of the day wasn't happy there
and every time 20 there was always a
limit the happiness it is is like an
illusion ya like like like like like
chasing a mirage yes chasing a mirage
exactly so then I began to be in this
group you know some members will do
things and still represent or carry like
this uniform of the whole organization
then they end up giving us a bad name so
all of a sudden I'm coming out of my
house and the cops come and snatched me
I'll put me in the car you know come
with us I'm like whether i did i just
woke up oh you rob this house as i just
woke up so they did it you didn't do it
yes so you're getting pin because of
other friends because you're hanging
with them your associate you're
affiliated with coming bad elements and
now it's coming back on ezel so
sometimes you know there will be you
know robbery will take place you know
sometimes just for fun okay we let's say
somebody you know we we want to take
something from what do it but whenever
that was done I always felt guilty I
always felt like you know if I took this
precious money you know that could be
for their family that could be for the
kids so I always felt guilty and and
then I began asking myself you know what
is you know what is going to happen
today's am I going to die today
am I gonna go to jail today you know is
my mother gonna get her as she's walking
with me just because I got a label and
others are not our Miss representing
this group you know and then it became
like a majority and then the people that
I trusted the people that I trusted that
I look up to they ended up you know i'll
tell you the story briefly i happened to
be in the puerto rican parade in New
York singing Puerto Rico oh you know and
two to my friends that I I thought they
were amongst the law in the lawyers
there with me and then the next day I'm
and work I see them in the news mm-hmm
they got killed dead they got killed
they're not walking erf anymore they got
killed finish wow wow by whom from the
same circle the same gang for the people
that are some of the people that I trust
the same family supposed family they so
one of them what the interesting thing
is that before that happened remember I
said there was a friend that was living
in the street and I told my mom to
please let him stay in my house this
friend the one that lived in the shelter
one of those people that killed my
friends had told him ok that the Quran
has wisdom so now the Quran which we
know is the verbatim word of God gets
mentioned here guess mansion yes so that
friend of Mines when he staying with me
in my house who said this now the one
that got killed that the one the one
that it's in jet it does in jail right
now doing 35 to life because he was
reading it in the in the in the print
outside no outside yeah so he advised my
other friend and that he told him that
the Quran has wisdom so me and my friend
when he was staying in my house we we
went to the library public library and
he was interested because he was it was
a reader yes yeah I was more into
basketball and he we got like five bucks
out and then finally and in Jersey we
reached our limit
but we came across local em so like okay
we can't take it on I said don't worry I
got it so I ended up taking the Quran
from the public library and we we left
it in my house it wasn't red but one
then my dad's friend moved out and then
that's when my friends got killed and
some incidents happen that made me
really like think about life and I
happened to be out with some friends the
result of hanging out of you know
drinking and lawyer saying he would die
for you for your brother you would die
for your friend but they might not be
ready to die for you so what happened
was I ended up going to jail because of
my friends again so so it was all this
being in in there just for one day made
me really think and say you know I want
to be home I want to be I want to wake
up at whatever time I want and go into
my refrigerator and eat whatever I want
wake up I whatever time I want I don't
want to be any so I said you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna change so that
thought led me to when I came out of of
jail the only one that bailed me out was
my mother we're not not your none of my
friends gang member forever and even
though I was in position nobody you had
some ready still didn't coming nobody
came to help me nobody except your
mother except my mother the one that
every day was stressed out worried about
me so when I came out I began to ask God
for guidance so I went to I went to
different churches and I started
collecting Bibles and then as I'm in my
house reading I remembered that I had
the Quran now I had no I had known a
little bit about Islam but I wasn't
interested in it through basketball
because uh when Michael Jordan retired
and I used to love the Bulls and then
I'm like what was going
my favorite team now so then I you know
I picked the next because it was loco I
could see the games so then also it was
in the finals the next vs houston so my
brother liked it Houston and then as I
was observing the game scene hakeem
olajuwon fasting in the playoffs yeah
you know was really impressive and then
another player that I really like the
style of play that I try to emulate was
booed up the road from Denver who his
name is to be Chris Jackson so I came in
contact a little bit about with
information about Islam but after that
when I decided to look into the truth
and read the Bible I opened the Quran
and I said you know I'm just gonna take
whatever benefits me and I'm gonna leave
it you know whenever it says Allah I'm
just gonna say God because I don't know
what it means I'm not used to say mama
yeah so then as i'm reading and i read
the first chapter you know at a time
when I would go to my room lock the door
prostrate and cry saying God you know me
better than myself show me the right way
and I would not look back I will leave
everything behind show me the right way
and now when I will not look back that's
the meaning to my previous lifestyle
let's hold off right there don't lose
your place we got to take a break we'll
be right back with more my brother
Daniel your brother you're on the Dean
show sit tight when I outside everything
looks good you see the
hundred-thousand-dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here or
which is my job to go into someone's
heart from change their heart your job
is to topi what the truth is and the
alley over there is while we're sitting
here while i'm sitting here constantly
paying for the disease to kill was free
back here with Daniel letting us in on
your story coming in from doing what
just everyone is doing here just you
know chasing the material thing money's
not bringing your happiness this family
the gang is not bringing you happiness
you witness some of your good friends
who got killed by the same organization
confusion chaos and now you're ready to
get serious and you get the Bible's and
you get a crown and what happens now as
i was reading I said you know I'm going
to look at these books with no prejudice
I'm just going to look and see it for
guidance so at the same time I would
pray sometimes I would you know I would
want to go outside and Jane but I said
no I'm gonna stay in the room i'll read
you know and then i will feel i felt
better you were seriously i was saying i
was i was actually having an internal
battle with myself so as I as I spent
some time reading the Bible and i came
across the Quran and the first chapter
the Quran at a time when I'm like Who am
I going to ask for help Who am I going
to worship so then i said as i read the
verses in the first chapter that said ya
kin who do ye i canna Stan you alone do
we worship and you alone do we as well I
said that's what I'm going to do and
then i read the commentary and he said
the first step is to look for the way
and it's difficult and the second step
once you find the right way is to accept
it and the third after you accepted is
to stay in the right way so I said you
know I'm going to stay so I began i
continue reading as i spent nine months
reading the quran consistently but what
happened to the Bible or I i was
comparing yeah but there was one thing
that turned me
off when i went i decided to go to
church in am in the middle of the day to
pray and what took place is that it was
closed so I got upset I'm like why is
explosive somebody's in need at any time
of the day and they want a place where
they could concentrate and worship it
should be open for somebody that you
know somebody could be on the verge of
may be committing suicide yeah that
option has to be there so I said you
know what that's it i'm not going to go
to church so then I just continued
reading the Quran and the good thing
that this Quran had some commentary with
with biblical verses so what I would do
is whenever biblical verses came up i
would go and refer to the Bible to see
if it was what it was saying was true
and I spent nine months reading the
Quran and then I said I'm Muslim
whenever I read a verse that said you
know like read the fast I would fast on
so I had pain I didn't know when to
finish so i would fast it is that fray i
would pray and go give give charity how
would you pray how would you do I would
just make I would just make frustration
with with my intention and that's it I
didn't know how to but I just had the
intention and I was taking the dough
Quran as an order so whenever it had a
command I will try to implement it and
this God this created that you were
seeking guidance from did you have a
mental picture in your head was it
through a human being a saint what were
you thinking when you were saying God
guide me no I knew that there was a
creator and unseen creator unseen unseen
creator who has the power to do
everything beyond human comprehension so
I I just trusted it didn't go through
Jesus or through Mahama as I as I will
do not know as I read the Quran it
became the doubts and the unanswered
questions that I had before became
answered which is you know the the
belief in Jesus so I through reading the
Quran it became clear that he was a
messenger
God anywhere any and he will come the
second time and and I accepted it became
more understood so in after nine months
in 11 years ago I accepted Islam and
decided to serve God and serve humanity
through the service of God so I can see
me learning and happened to be that as I
was I began reading the Quran my my mom
sometimes we'll listen the English
translation and it was a blessing that
in two years later my mother accepted
Islam the mother that you mentioned
earlier there was a nun correct and she
accepted as she accepted Islam yeah and
then of four months later my dad accepts
his father hamdulillah hamdullah and
then after I became overjoyed because
God answered my prayers for them to be
guided not from me but for themselves
and they were guided and so then I you
know I made the intention to just work
and teach people Islam you also went
down to to study more the Arabic
language and to learn more about a song
you actually went to Egypt correct as I
was in the process of teaching like new
Muslims about Islam under the guidance
of the local Imam then I went to Egypt
to study Arabic so I could be able to
understand the quran' so I could
internalize the meaning and be able to
teach my children my wife and children
the Quran I have three children and my
wife I'm delay she's expecting any day
now and Hum Dil lab before I went to
Egypt add a great gift from Allah that
he guided my brother to brother also
hamdullah my older brother and now you
know after being in Egypt hamdullah for
almost four years I was blessed with
meeting good brothers so I met by the
mujaddid Fletcher from Islam in Spanish
and hamdulillah you know we shared the
same goals of helping the the Latino
community you know in educating them
about Islam so in coming back to the
States you know I joined them in with
Islamist vanish project and we only have
a couple more minutes so there I hear
there's a lot of Latinos coming to Islam
is this true correct correct they're
there is over there is around 200,000 as
a recent study and think I don't
remember the exact university name but
it was a recent research that was done
in the year two thousand and two there
was a study that said it was like on
40,000 but now he's increase in and we
were blessed today to be in in so having
an open house here locally and tomorrow
we're going to have another one here you
know in mashallah we had a good turnout
you know and and and we had an event
called the Islamic roots in the Latino
culture now tell us for those latinos
that are out there also and this whole
there's a lot of people from from this
community that are Catholic right you
got all the saints and you know going in
a confession box and here Hail Mary and
do this and this confusion I spoken to a
lot of Spanish people also and they're
confused as Trinity this down the other
and and and now they come to Islam
worship one God the Creator alone and
you leave all this confusion alone as
simple as rational it makes sense and
you know what they can connect with you
more because you speak the language the
language say something to the Latinos
out there that are also in this state
they're looking for peace money can't
get it you can't buy a six-pack of peace
talk to them and try to get them
motivated and they can where they can
look you up where you says Aslam yes you
could say stop talk to miss Pangaea the
lala land for my sin cooler weather is
la la pagina donde puede encontrar form
a single Islam is the Islam in Spanish
Punto oh hey
I see enters the the audio books
grabados con tomas la vida era el velero
mensaje a sous le lien de la verdad
attaining empathy says a cds gratis del
quran and Espanyol so you basically
working realize that that you can go to
the website and get these wowww diatomic
spanish dot org and you have access to
all of our audio books for free yeah
online and and even on youtube we have a
selection called Islamic Spanish TV so
all of our videos are there and people
have access to see it for free just to
benefit from it and make mcgraw files
pray for us I'm really excited that we
were coming to a close translated imma
go from English to Spanish there's only
one guy worship Him alone not his
creation callum in Spanish talk to him I
solo on Dios a dollar a solo ya know so
classy oh that's it thank you very much
thank you very much mikado might the
crater Allah reward you for being with
us and insha'Allah this is so short
we're going to have to do a part to
sound so next time you come in town
we're gonna have you back and so it
shall I gotta thank you very much i
found and that was our brother Daniel
went from looking for peace and all the
wrong places but he found it in the way
of life that was lived by all the
messengers of God you heard their names
before Abraham Noah Moses Jesus Christ
and the last and final messenger prophet
peace be upon him they all lived Islam
they all taught this beautiful way of
life to acquire peace that's what we all
want that's what we all need and how you
going to get it opening up that six-pack
chasing that young lady that's not your
wife or a young man no you can't buy it
you need to submit yourself entirely to
the one God the one God who created this
whole universe and everything in it the
one God that Jesus prostrate it to and
you could prostrate to them too right
now just like Daniel did
he cleared out any images of God every
false notion that was out there vodka he
cleared it out and he asked the Creator
earnestly guide me guide me guide me
that's what you gotta do do it in
Spanish do it in Chinese doing man ray
whatever it is just do it do it and then
from there be courageous enough to
submit and follow the truth and come
back here every week to the Dean show
you can go to the website Islam in
Spanish org if you have some of your
friends who are out there who want to
learn more about this beautiful way of
life but they don't speak English you
can for your latino friends and brothers
direct them there they have cdo's audios
and remember to pick up the dean show
DVD make copies of it share this message
of peace with the world we'll see you
next time inshallah God willing until
then peace be unto you